i want sal to come completely clean
about
sal first of all sent me a note he said
uh howard another bit lifted
jon stewart sent one of his anchors out
to interview people with the question
what race would you eliminate from the
earth
last month we wrote and he writes
broadcasted which is improper
an almost identical question so he sent
it to me and i didn't think anything of
it i just said you know who cares
then in the email fred forwards me the
email howard
john stewart sent one of his anchors out
to interview people with the question
what race would you eliminate from the
earth last month we wrote and
broadcasted an almost identical question
i think what sal does and i've always
suspected this
he sends email to the show about how
great sal is why would a listener say
last month
yes you did come clean come clean it's
your exact email you imbecile
i saw that too i was like that's weird
how
i'm not kidding swear on the life of
your children that isn't you sending
that in
i swear in the life of my children last
month we wrote and broadcasted
it's the exact grammatical no maybe it's
an aaron
and fred's system no no no no no no no
no no no no
no look i want you to free and liberate
yourself because the truth is the best
liberator
dude why would i send the same email
through a fake why would an
emailer say last month we wrote and
broadcasted
that's exactly what you said the email
it wouldn't be broadcasting
no we didn't wrote why did the emailers
say we wrote
i don't know i don't know how it got why
would he use the word broadcasted
which when the word is broadcast i sent
the same email to you
i know why would i duplicate it in a
fake email
did i [ __ ] up because you [ __ ] up well
i don't know
look at me i didn't send you you hit the
wrong show
i'm going to ask you i might have i'm
going to ask you again and if you lie to
me
if you lie to me then i'll know you're a
filthy liar wait dude wait a minute look
at me
don't wait a minute look at me i want
you to come clean
there's not going to be a repercussion
if you're honest i'm not sending you
it's the exact identical email now look
me in the eye
and tell me what happened for real dude
i
that must be an error i wouldn't send
wow
look at me oh just tell me how
many times you've done this i've never
done it i'm not the only time if you lie
to me i'm going to get rid of you if you
tell me the truth
i'll keep i'm not lying to you now
liberate yourself
liberal tell the truth dude the only
child no no no no no sal look at me
don't give me your [ __ ] i'm not
bullshitting
i'm not bus so you're claiming that this
email that's identical to the email you
sent me
it's an error [ __ ] it's an error an
error what does that mean
i have no idea i don't know
gary's holding a [ __ ] why are you doing
this to me
i can't take it anymore you'll take it
no
get back in your cubby home make phony
phone calls goodbye